So, now, let's spend a little bit of
time trying to get an intuition of what
this M matrix is.
So, the best way to think about what
an image moment is, an image moment is
a particularly weighted average
of image pixel intensities,
and it could also be a function of those
intensities, and it's used to basically
give us certain specific property
at a point within an image.
So, any image, shown by this rectangle
here, at any point I want to be able to
find some properties that
are kind of descriptive and
something I can actually
find about an image.
Now of course, what we will leverage
here is information driven by
the derivatives at that point.
So the derivatives, of course,
can be measured using various types of
things we've looked at and from that,
I can find a gradient vector, the
magnitude of that, and the direction.
The second moment matrix is
specifically a matrix derived from
the gradient of this function that
could be actually at this point.
And it summarizes the predominant
directions of the gradient
of a specified neighborhood
of that point.
So around that point, basically now,
gives you more information about
the direction and the magnitude.
One additional thing that's important
about the second moment matrix
is it also gives you a little bit more
information about the coherency of
the directions in that neighborhood.
So let's look at the equation of how we
would compute the second moment matrix.
Basically again, it is the intensities,
sorry, the derivative of
the intensities in X and Y direction,
and then the mixtures of these X and Y's
on the diagonals or off-diagonals, and
computed over any neighborhood point.
And of course the neighborhood
search is this region here.
So again, simply put, if I had
an image like this basically I can use
a second Loman matrix to at any point in
the neighborhood around that point find
description using the gradients that
is unique to this point, and actually I
want to use this to understand more
about what's happening in the region and
that could be used to now compute the
information about if there's a corner
and what kinds of parameters associated
with that corner in that image.
Think the note of course is,
and we've talked about this,
is the importance of the ellipse and
the argon values.
Again, something that
we've looked at before.
Of course, when you have certain bits
of information, and again, if you think
about it this way, with the moments it's
kind of giving you information what's
the best possible rotation
around these two different axes.
And, of course,
we use this to define two major axes.
Or, sorry, one, for
this ellipse a minor and the major axes.
And this kind of gives us what's the
most dominant direction for this region.
And that's what we're interested in
here, is at any point in an image,
finding these types of ellipsoids, and
using these ellipsoids to
find the dominant directions.
And, of course, recall that item values
provide us with this information.